money's come on me for my mama Nick this
already beating my mama so me and my
powers are in my room
and we can hear my mom getting beaten up
so I had to bang it and I've got it now
I wish I'd have bought it now damn right
so what I'm gonna do I'll take a video
over that and send it okay so you can
show it I'll show you all right yeah I'm
gonna buy in it so now I've seen the
paint on the floor so I'll sit in my
power pick up a weapon I'll peel around
I'll be going through him we'll do my
dad we gotta do him he's gonna kill my
mum so I'll run down the stairs I'm
running the kitchen I'll put like my
applications now touch my mum again I'll
kill you Joe I mean touch my mum
again and I'll kill you and he was he
backed up like that as he's backed up I
sort of pushed him and then he stepped
back and I sort of thought he's gone and
I pushed him back and I've got him to
that outside the house and then he's off
and then but he's there how old are you
here um I think 14 or 14 I was 14 yeah